[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm adding another video to
the how strong is series I thought it
was a good time to finally covers
eldress because of the new demon king
power up his body has undergone recently
in the manga if you have someone else
you'd like to see this type of video
done for let your boy know in the
comments for more seven deadly sins make
sure to LIKE and subscribe to anime out
drawer you can always get even more
seven deadly sins content and crucial
updates by following us on Instagram at
anime uproar keep in mind there will be
manga spoilers in this video so you
Netflix only fans make sure to proceed
with caution what I do in these videos
is go over the characters notable
achievements in terms of strength and
use all of the evidence available to
determine how strong the character is
currently so let's start at the
beginning the ten commandments are
immediately hyped up as being
ridiculously strong as Hawke points out
Mele Otis is scared stiff when he senses
that they are awake he is trembling and
sweating then we jump directly to a full
page of zeldron suggesting that he is
the one that caused Mellie Otis is
scared reaction more than anyone else he
is also the one giving orders to the
other commandments and leading them so
from the beginning he is positioned by
the seven deadly sins creator naka ba as
the strongest of the ridiculously strong
when Mel Yoda stakes on the Ten
Commandments zelgius effortlessly takes
off belly Otis's arm he's so quick that
he has taken out his sword slice smelly
Otis's arm off and put his sword back in
its holder before anyone could even see
his blade not only is he faster dan Mele
ODIs with the sword his swordsmanship is
set to be the fastest in all of the
demon realm so it just doesn't need to
go all out at this point because Esther
OSA takes out Mele Otis so we don't get
to see more of soldiers power during
this battle three thousand years ago we
find out that zelgius effortlessly
overpowered roll the king of giants
someone was a giant among Giants and
always strive to be the strongest later
it seems like zelgius meliodas cusack
and Chandler might have their work
for them when Arthur unlocks some
Excalibur's power but Cusack lets him
know that his attacks didn't actually do
squat as Cusack says the four of them
including Sandra's are the highest order
of demon and even the combined power of
the strongest humans excluding High Noon
Eskin or can't do anything to them
except maybe give them a nice moustache
trim between zell dresses battles we are
told that as the brother of Melly Otis
and the son of the demon king he is the
only other one besides Melly Otis who
could handle the power of the Ten
Commandments back in Chapter 261 speed
tells us Teresa that it's one thing for
Melly Otis and Zell drous but if a
serosa tries to take in any more
Commandments they'll surely destroy him
it's not only like that for a serosa
though it's like that for most beings
except as Mon speed mentioned formerly
Otis and Zell drous thus is eldress
eventually absorbing the demon Kings
powers was foreshadowed long ago his
strength was well above the other demons
in the demon world and even comparable
to Melly Otis's as won't speed implies
it isn't until the new holy war arc that
we really get to see zelgius flex in
Chapter 287 we get to see his original
power ominous nebula I put this ability
in my top-10 overpowered abilities in
the seven deadly sins video because of
how crazy strong it is Merlin explains
how it works through an extreme ultimate
state of concentration the zelgius
accelerates the darkness within his own
body and spirals it around him creating
a vortex that pulls in all living things
around him with a terrifying force any
and everything that enters that area
will be shredded to ribbons with such
blinding speed that even the absolute
spinal reflexes of a living organism
could not dodge them in time buddha
shell at this point has a power level of
200 and 1,000 and the grace flash which
is known for its speed and yet he is
powerless before zelgius attack he
suggests that the attack is so fast it
doesn't just equal divine territory it
surpasses it combined with the power
that he borrowed from the demon
King that made him immune to magic
attacks zelgius is all but invincible
unlucky for him though it happens to be
high noon and Eska Knorr legendary the
one form does manage to stop the attack
with a karate chop however keep in mind
that zelgius has zero Commandments at
this point Mele Otis is in the process
of absorbing them all now that he
currently has all ten commandments which
supposedly gave him half of the demon
Kings power
I couldn't even cska Knorr the one
standing a chance keep in mind no matter
how strong the one is it is supposed to
be but a fraction of the supreme deities
power a figure who is supposed to be
about equal in strength to the demon
king but more on demon Kings I'll just
later even with no Commandments zelgius
manages to survive a combined attack
from SK Knorr 2:1 and Ludo show not only
that but he manages to recover fast
enough to hold back a spirit spear from
Harlequin with full-grown wings and a
mile with sunshine who is at this point
stronger than Eska Knorr the one this
version of mild not only took care of
the original demon in a single attack he
also managed to stop ominous nebula by
simply getting close to the attack his
closeness alone melted zelgius a sword
that zelgius had used to block ESCA
Norris karate chop zelgius does not
defeat them but he does get some good
hits on mile and he manages to do what
he wanted to do he manages to fight them
long enough for Mele Otis to come out of
the cocoon of course it turns out that
it's not really Mele Otis that's in
control of his body but the demon king
that is using Mele Otis's body as a
vessel after taking a beating from Eska
Norris the one ludo shell king with
full-grown wings and mile with sunshine
zelgius should be out for the rest of
the fight but no he even has enough
energy to stop two of demon king Mele
Otis's deadly attacks the combined
efforts of mile with sunshine lunar
shell and king with full-grown wings
were not enough to stop the grieving
sage attack but zelgius did it even
though he took more damage than all of
them up to that point then the demon
king takes bags of justice immunity to
magic attacks and gives him one of the
most serious injuries we've seen so far
in
manga yet he survives even this Meli
oldest man just to kick his dad out of
his body but Cusack managed to help
zelgius absorb all of the 10
commandments after doing so demon king
zelgius effortlessly takes out Cusack a
demon of the highest order now we have a
villain truly fit for the ridiculously
powerful Mele Otis I gotta admit I had
absolutely no idea how anyone could
challenge Mele Otis at this point
because he seemed so overpowered but
this actually makes sense remember
everything it took for the sense to be -
demon king Mele Otis it took Mele Otis
raging war on the inside of his body and
the combined efforts of zeldron
bond after purgatory and everyone else
now assuming zelgius won't be able to
overpower the demon king on the inside
which is a fair assumption in my view
the sins will have to take on an
undistracted demon king who can give his
all to the battle on the physical plane
zelgius was Opie enough with a combo of
ominous nebula and magic resistance but
with all 10 commandments in him and the
experienced demon king controlling his
body we will see a completely different
level of strength as mentioned before
zelgius was comparable to Mele Otis both
brothers were strong enough already to
be able to handle the 10 commandments
without their bodies self-destructing
Mele Otis felt like he needed to absorb
the 10 commandments to equal his
father's strength and break his curse
which we were told required equal or
greater strength after he lost the Ten
Commandments Mele Otis thought that his
own awaken power would be enough to
destroy the curse however the curse came
back suggesting that currently with his
awaken power his power is not equal to
the demon kings
if you recall the demon king had split
his power more than once first he gave
part of it to the original demon then he
split it again to create the ten
commandments he was also letting zelgius
borrow some power for a long time now
that both Cusack and Chandler are dead
meaning the power he lent to the
original demon could come back to him
and the Ten Commandments are all inside
zelgius it seems that all of the power
ever split in the past could be
concentrated in cell juses body if he
proceeds to somehow transfer over his
purgatory self that has been absorbing
power in purgatory for the equivalent of
over a billion and a half human years
then he will be more powerful than he's
ever been he will have all of his power
in one place and you can add to that is
Elvis's own impressive power that I've
tried to illustrate in this video taking
all this into account we can start to
see why the demon king indulgences body
looks so calm even though he's seen what
Mele Otis is capable of so how strong is
demon king zelgius right now it seems
safe to say that he is the strongest
character in the series Mele Otis will
need a power boost help from the sins
and maybe even Milan the one mode to
even stand a chance against his father
if he did in fact manage to concentrate
all of his power in zelgius his body let
me know how you think our main
characters could possibly defeat demon
King's eldest in the comments of this
video
I'm so excited especially after we went
from an epilogue which implied that the
series was gonna end shortly to chapter
312 which is called the war begins
suggesting a brand new arc is just
getting on their way I could not be more
thankful and hyped about this and that's
it for today's video thank you so much
for watching if you liked the video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
for more seven deadly sins videos we
have a brand new war beginning which
like I said I'm psyched about and the
next anime season is also coming in the
fall so you can expect a lot more 7
Deadly Sins content coming your way you
can get the latest seven deadly sins
updates and more content on our
instagram at anime uproar a huge thank
you goes out to all of our patrons who
helped make all of these videos possible
especially to our pro tier patrons chubs
and the one and only Gilgamesh and the
one tier patrons the ones who stay atop
all clans Ahmad and Radha a Lola and
autumn James Maddy Mac ace and
our first ever acknowledged one-tier
patron the one acknowledged by Lord we
go senpai sama himself baby ray thanks
again for all the support and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]